bonjour rené chiche merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur rt france
vous avez annoncé lire sur votre compte
twitter vouloir suspendre votre cour le
2 novembre prochain en espérant le
soutien de vos collègues enseignants
pourquoi ce geste symbolique et est ce
que vous avez déjà eu des retours de la
part de vos collègues par rapport à
cette annonce oui effectivement j'ai
annoncé vous m'entendez bien j'espère un
j'ai avancé que j'allais évidemment sans
la moindre hésitation afficher ses
caricatures mais pas seulement les
affichée par les rendre hommage à notre
collègue
d'après une chose que je voudrais dire
deux bords c'est que je suis j'éprouve
une infinie tristesse mais également une
colère infinie et qui est alimenté par
le chapelet d'intervention que vous
venez de produire sur votre reportage
précédent parce que la plupart de ces
gens et notamment ceux qui ont été aux
responsabilités ont laissé l'école dans
un état déplorable se déliter vous savez
le titre du livre que vous avez cités
c'est pas la destruction me servez là d
un profileur la destruction voilà des
instructions je voudrais je voudrais
commencer par donc effectivement dire à
quel point je suis meurtri et
profondément touché mais comme je les ai
été ou au mois de janvier 2015 et au
mois de janvier 2015 le 7 janvier 2015
j'ai eu l'espoir que nous allions
regarder la réalité en face et nous
poser les bonnes questions et ça n'a pas
été fait et aujourd'hui mais ce n'est
que le énième épisode d'une descente aux
enfers qui n'a absolument pas de terme
aujourd'hui j'espère encore je vous le
dis très solennellement que nous allons
regarder la réalité en face parce que il
ya plusieurs éléments dans cette affaire
évidemment on a là on a la victime la
plus la puce symbolique qu'on puisse
avoir après des journalistes c'est à
dire un professeur et donc c'est
clairement un acte d'une portée
considérable considérable et je pense
que tout le monde se rend compte mais
drg aussi un bourreau qui est où un
assassin qui est une espèce d'aubaine
pour certains puisque effectivement il
vient d'arriver en france c'est que on
peut se demander ce qu'ils faisaient là
ce qui est beaucoup plus grave en
réalité est que on dit beaucoup moins
c'est que un très grand nombre de
professeurs ont peur ont peur et n'osent
plus aborder un certain nombre de sujets
dans leur classe se font en permanence
surveiller et réprimandé par leur
hiérarchie qui est elle même soumise à
une pression absolument inconcevable de
la part-dieu ce qu'on appelle des
parents d'élèves
il faut quand même voilà il ya il ya
celui qui tient le couteau
là maintenant quitté couteau n'est pas
forcément la main qui dirige l'acte et
moi j'ai été extrêmement choqué par les
menaces qui ont été proférées par un
parent d'élève qui s'est même vanté sur
les réseaux et s'il est capable de se
vanter sur les réseaux d'intel d'un tel
propos et d'une telle menace puisqu'il a
souhaité explicitement à la démission de
ce professeur il l'a qualifiée d'
incompétent c'est que l'état de notre
école est en crise et ces sectes
vraiment dans votre les voilà justement
dans votre livre la d instruction
nationale vous pointez du doigt un
système scolaire défaillant des élèves
en trop grande difficulté auront quitté
le lycée notamment qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous proposait alors
concrètement puisque comme
vous avez dit dans la guirlande de
réactions des politiques et vous n'êtes
pas satisfait qu est ce que vous vous
proposez vous proposer pour éviter ce
genre de drame
alors déjà j'ai effectivement je ne suis
pas satisfait d'abord je ne suis pas
satisfait et je suis très bien comme ça
qu'on parle de terrorisme pour un acte
qui est un acte de folie alors quand
j'ai dit folie ça on parle du tout
l'auteur de cet acte irresponsable
quand on est moins bien mais il faut
nommer les choses l'islamisme radical
la théocratie c'est ce que niche appelé
les illuminés de l'ariège monde c'est à
dire ce sont des fous il faut le dire
sauf que on ne peut pas continuer à
tolérer et à entretenir au sein même de
la société française une telle folie
alors proposé le rempart contre la folie
le rempart contre l'obscurantisme se
saouler et ce sont les lumières c'est à
dire c'est l'éducation l'éducation et
l'instruction
moi je veux absolument que l'on remette
en remette complètement l'instruction au
centre de l'école qu'on arrête de
s'excuser de devoir inséminer telle et
telle chose et que les parents d'élèves
soient remis à leur place leur place qui
n'est pas du tout d'être dans l'école et
de se mêler de l'école ni nous devons
accorder la priorité à l'esprit des
jeunes gens parce que c'est sur l'esprit
des jeunes gis sur l'avenir de la
république
et est ce que vous vous sentez en
insécurité dans le cadre de votre
travail notamment après ce qui s'est
passé et dans quel état d'esprit sont
vos confrères alors moi personnellement
et effectivement j'ai annoncé
publiquement que j'allais afficher ses
caricatures ne serait ce que pour rendre
hommage à mon collègue samuel qui en est
mort
et certains parmi mes collègues ont
salué mon courage moi j'ai pas du tout
le sentiment de faire preuve de courage
en faisant cela j'ai simplement le le
sentiment de faire un devoir
si on en est à imaginer qu'on risque sa
vie parce qu'on fait son devoir c'est
que il ya quelque chose qui va pas ma
france et cette chose qui nous
car en france il faut l'avoir en face
encore une fois il faut se servir de ce
qui s'est passé pour poser les bonnes
questions et pour l'instant je ne
m'entends pas les bonnes questions
j'entends la ritournelle habituelle il
faut pas faire d'amalgamé
il faut faire attention qu'il ne faut
pas choquer les susciter les
susceptibilités des uns et des autres
mais ce n'est pas du tout le sujet ce
n'est pas du tout le sujet nous nous
sommes dans le pays des lumières le pays
qui a donné au monde un certain nombre
de valeurs que les parties du monde les
plus avancés illustre défendent à leur
tour et nous on a l'impression qu'on les
défende plus et on va se on va quand
même pas se laisser impressionner par
une idéologie moyenâgeuse jeudi dans la
joute est justement jean castex et jean
michel blanquer refait la laïcité un qui
a été touché comment protéger au mieux
cette valeur essentielle de la
république à l'école oui enfin bon ce
sont de la part de jean castex et de
jean michel blanquer
ce sont simplement des mots jean michel
blanquer en lui même est très très au
fait de ce que la laïcité est absolument
maltraités au sein de l'éducation
nationale
je vous signale que nous avons un
instituteur il ya quelques années il ya
deux trois ans et qui a été sanctionné
par l'institution elle même et par jean
michel blanquer puisqu'il en est le
responsable parce qu'ils avaient faits
étudiés étudier la religion au travers
de certains textes notamment de certains
textes issus de la bible et
que les mêmes personnes quelques temps
après ils vont aux évoqué la té alors
qu'on a cassé q tu es un instituteur en
lui reprochant de faire entorse à la
laïcité parce qu'il faisait son travail
d'instruction
eh bien je trouve cela absolument
scandaleux donc à un moment donné
l'hypocrisie doit cesser moi je j'ai su
de ma part là dans ce combat il va
falloir dire les choses clairement et ne
plus accepter les faux fuyants
bon là on l'a on aurait dû le faire dès
le 7 janvier 2015
bon et bien à partir du 16 octobre 2020
là c'est terminé il faut il faut que
chacun prenne enfin ses responsabilités
merci rené cherche d'abord à répondre à
une question on le rappelle vous êtes
professeur de philosophie vice-président
du syndicat réaction et démocratie et
auteur du livre la désastre uction
nationale aux éditions nova dire